[Music]
it was always just my mom and me
to have a family that's what i really
want
no way i got a cousin that is the
whitest man i've ever seen he wants to
meet up
oliver cousin evie it sounds so
jane austen when you say it like that
you know my mom always wanted to take me
to england to learn about our family
history there's a wedding coming up
actually you should come i would love to
but come on everyone is dying to meet
you
[Music]
wow it's incredible
i believe this is one of our important
guests evie this is a close friend of
the family walter deville uh hi hi
looking forward to getting to know you
better
[Music]
what are you doing down there
miss you should return to your room
we're all so delighted that you're here
which one's the ground the groom and his
bride will make their grand entrance
tomorrow
ready
i i can't shake the feeling that
everyone is staring at me
you and walter seem to be getting
awfully close evie
i'm curious though what have you told
you
about us ow
let me see
there she is where are the bride and
groom
as you all know there has been someone
missing from this table
but that once broken bond will be
renewed tonight
to even
my new bride
i want to go home but this is your home
help me please
yeah dear hello mr hawker here there's a
young lady who seems quite distressed
i'm so glad you've come to your senses
my love
[Music]
bye
[Music]